nobody likes a bad movie but nobody
hates a flop any more than the Stars
themselves whip out some Rotten Tomatoes
because these major movie stars got
defensive over their boxed office bombs
it's no surprise that Hollywood's always
been enamored with the tale of Robin
Hood a do-gooder who battles the
tyrannical villain to help the less
fortunate Robin Hood is a medieval
superhero but reimagining folk tales as
gritty action movies seems like a bit of
a tired idea really inspiring thanks so
in 2018 when Robin Hood hit theaters
starring Taran egerton as the bow
wielding Rogue a bombed at the box
office but in the aftermath of the
movie's failure Edgerton was quick to
throw blame and defend his part in the
film in an interview with variety
eckerton claimed it was absolutely not
the movie that I signed up to make it
was pitched to me in a different way
what that way could have been we're not
sure but perhaps they left the dark
gritty reboot part out when selling him
on the film whatever the case may be the
star believed the film's problems boiled
down to excessive Studio meddling what
do you do my duty Loxley
we have new orders from above like it or
not Soldier we're all powerless here
egerton explained what he thought
happened saying I think it was made by
committee and I think it lost its Vision
I wasn't very happy on set I didn't have
a very happy time making it
arguably one of the most infamous comic
book flops 2004's Catwoman started out
in the 1990s as a spin-off featuring
Michelle Pfeiffer's character from
Batman Returns but after years in
development hell actress Ali Berry took
over the role a critical and box office
bomb the film took home a number of
worst awards at the razzies the
following year White Russian no ice hold
the vodka
regardless star Halle Berry has never
been ashamed of this one even showing up
in person to collect her worst actress
Razzie in fact she's always defended the
film and had plenty to say about it in
response to its harshest critics telling
the daily mail it was definitely
different from any other movie I had
seen I thought that we needed a better
villain but I was outnumbered in that
area like Edgerton on Robinhood Barry
also talked about the struggles of
assessing a project even after it's
produced saying you just never know how
people are going to respond for example
I thought that Monster's Ball was going
to end my career and look what happened
you just never know you never know is
right Barry took home an Academy Award
for her work in Monsters ball
if Catwoman was the biggest comic book
movie bust of the 2000s morbius is its
2020 successor centered on the titular
vampire anti-hero played by Jared Leto
morbius was Savaged by critics becoming
the butt of jokes that helped fuel
long-running internet memes but despite
the negative reaction and lack of box
office bucks Matt Smith who played the
movie's villain didn't let it get him
down and I will not go back you cannot
make me go back I won't know you make me
come back
the former Doctor Who star told Rolling
Stone it was thrown under the bus but
you just have to roll with it what else
are you gonna do unwilling to be dragged
down by the film's failure Smith
insisted that everything be put in the
proper perspective he elaborated it's a
film at the end of the day we're not
saving lives for whatever reason it
didn't quite work out and it is what it
is
can we really call Black Adam a bomb it
certainly wasn't a hit Studio execs were
expecting not even pulling in 400
million on a reported 200 million dollar
budget black panther wakanda forever
amassed more domestically in just three
days than Black Adam did in its entire
run and the DC film fell to fourth place
in less than 30 days but Dwayne The Rock
Johnson got defensive at the mere
suggestion that his movie compared
unfavorably to wakanda Forever its major
rival at the box office he tweeted
there's no competition with the
established Global brand of black
panther compared to Black Adam and JSA
who a year ago no one even heard of were
new babies and have to grow there is no
we here there are only Heroes and
they're villains meanwhile when variety
outright called the film a bust Johnson
pushed back on Twitter saying our film
will profit we are building our new
franchise step by step not long after
Johnson reportedly leaked a misleading
financial statement to refute claims of
the film losing money an unusual tactic
for a major star to say the least
cats was a celebrated Tony award-winning
Broadway musical that it wasn't adapted
to film until 2019 is actually somewhat
surprising it would have made a
delightful Disney animated movie instead
audiences got a live-action retelling
starring the likes of Judy Dench Ian
McKellen Taylor Swift and Idris Elba all
digitally dolled up as bizarre
anthropomorphic human cat hybrids
critics and audiences were baffled and
horrified in equal measure and the film
was a major disaster all the way around
but the cast Never wavered Jennifer
Hudson who played grissabella in the
film was particularly defensive in the
face of harsh critical response in a
2021 interview with total film Hudson
said you know what I think it was a bit
overwhelming it's unfortunate that it
was misunderstood I think later down the
line people will see it differently but
whether the film improves with age or
remains misfire Hudson has no regrets
claiming it is something I'm still very
proud of and grateful to have been a
part of
I got to be grizzabella the glamor cat
in the late 2000s sci-fi and fantasy
franchises were delivering Blockbuster
box office returns and Disney wanted to
kick-start one of their own Carter
in 2012 the studio released the
ill-fated flop John Carter it was
slammed by critics for its confusing
story and coherent plot and nonsensical
characters becoming one of the biggest
box office disasters of the 2000s if
anyone had reason to be angry it would
be Taylor Kitsch who played the titular
Carter but despite all the derision the
movie received and the money the film
Lost kich maintained that it wasn't a
flop at all saying I don't see it as a
failure that's the thing I'm incredibly
proud of it and I would do it all over
again pointing out that the film still
sold plenty of tickets added if someone
told me that my first lead film will
make well over 300 million dollars
that's a good thing but the actor was
most offensive about his own role in the
film insisting any shortcomings had
nothing to do with them he alleged I
know personally I literally did
everything possible I could have in John
Carter that's why I prepped so hard and
why I pushed myself so hard so I can
have no regrets
another notorious money bet Julie was a
romantic crime Thriller from 2003
starring Ben Affleck and Jennifer Lopez
about a pair of crooks who screw up a
kidnapping plot Affleck and Lopez began
dating during production which prompted
the studio to rewrite the script the
movie ended up being a total disaster
earning back a fraction of its budget
and getting roasted by critics
Aflac blamed the studio for playing up
the publicity around the real-life
romance telling Entertainment Weekly
because I had begun having this
relationship with Jennifer Lopez which
was selling a lot of magazines and
appeared to generate a lot of enthusiasm
they just predictably latched onto they
want a romantic comedy they want the two
of them together more of that but Lopez
went further openly admitting that the
film sucked and in appearance on Late
Night with Seth Meyers Lopez got a bit
defensive when pressed yeah there's
worse movies than Julie out there yeah
absolutely okay bud Lopez Mike Affleck
admitted that their relationship which
was getting all the attention during
filming was at least part of the film's
problem
oh I know we got we got a lot of crap at
that time and because we were together
it was a whole other thing going on as
well adapted from the iconic TV series
The Lone Ranger was thought to be the
next big franchise for Disney and Johnny
Depp who'd had Blockbuster success with
Pirates of the Caribbean Lone Ranger was
anything but a blockbuster however
losing an estimated 200 million but that
didn't seem to bother the film stars
Johnny Depp and Armie Hammer who brushed
off any suggestion that the movie had
failed in an interview with Yahoo movies
Depp said I think the reviews were
written seven to eight months before we
released the film I think the reviews
were written when they heard Gore
verbinsky and Jerry Bruckheimer and me
were going to do the Lone Ranger they
had expectations that it must be a
blockbuster I didn't have any
expectations of that I never do
[Music]
Hammer meanwhile was more feisty in his
defense than the film asserting that if
you go back and read the negative
reviews most of them aren't about the
content of the movie but more what's
behind it it's got to the point with
American critics where if you're not as
smart as Plato you're stupid that seems
like a sad way to live your life Hammer
believes the Press piled on in a
critical Feeding Frenzy adding I think
it was the popular thing when the movie
hit Rocky terrain they jumped on the
bandwagon to try and Bash it
although the Thriller Serenity boasted a
stellar cast it launched in 2019 to
little Fanfare in addition to Stars
Matthew McConaughey and Anne Hathaway it
also featured Diane Lane Jason Clark
jimin hansu and Jeremy Strong the film
tells the story of a divorced boat
captain who reluctantly comes to the aid
of his ex-wife when she wants to have
her abusive husband taken out of the
picture I want you to take him out on
your boat
and drop him in the ocean for the Sharks
unfortunately the movie failed to
connect with critics or audiences and
didn't even make back its modest budget
but Hathaway wasn't deterred by the
film's poor critical or commercial
reception and took to social media to
defend her work she posted we keep it
real around here some critics get
Serenity and like me find it interesting
moving ambitious and indifferent and for
some it just doesn't work that's cool
sometimes we do bad things for good
reasons Hathaway appeared to accept that
not everyone has to like a project but
her defense was more than just a
fair-minded retort in fact the actress
seemed to take personal offense to the
bad reviews writing there is no failure
only learned events not everyone has to
like everything and the critical
response doesn't change my feelings
about the movie however other people's
time and money are not to be taken for
granted so I just want to be clear I
endorsed the movie many critics don't
produced by Judd Apatow Rose is a
romantic comedy written by and starring
comedian Billy Eichner it focuses on two
men who are decidedly not looking for
commitment but nevertheless fall in love
despite praise for its lgbtq cast
including Luke McFarland T.S Madison and
Eichner himself the film bombed at the
box office but unlike most flops on this
list Bros received critical Acclaim for
its clever comedy Earnest story in heart
as a result Eichner was more than just
disappointed by the film's take at the
ticket counter as he lashed out at both
critics and at audiences while defending
its failure in some since deleted
Twitter comments Eichner put the blame
on homophobic audiences who refused to
show up for the well-reviewed film
tweeting straight people especially in
certain parts of the country just didn't
show up for Bros everyone who isn't a
homophobic weirdo should go see Bros
tonight
but despite his emotional Outburst Ogden
did make a few valid points writing
Rolling Stone already has Bros on the
list of the best comedies of the 21st
century what's also true is that at one
point a theater chain called Universal
said they were pulling the trailer
because of the gay content although the
studio convinced the theater to continue
running the trailer evidence suggests
that we still have a long way to go
before lgbtq content is completely
accepted and celebrated by the American
moviegoer
[Music]